[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute möchte ich wieder was Herzhaftes backen.
Deswegen gibt es bei uns heute Pizza-Donuts,
ein Fingerfood,
was hoffentlich später ganz gut aussieht.
Die Basis ist...
Die Baustelle da draußen, die nervt mich total!
Aber das ist nicht schlimm.
Ich ignoriere den Lärm einfach.
Ich singe ihn einfach weg.
Die Basis ist ein Hefeteig,
den ich eigentlich immer für Pizza zubereite.
Ja.
Die Basis ist ein Hefeteig, den ich immer...
Das war ein sehr falscher Satz.
Die Basis ist ein Hefeteig,
den ich für meine Pizza präferiere.
Oh, das klingt doch gut.
Dafür verwende ich
einen halben Würfel Hefe,
einen Teelöffel Zucker,
250 Milliliter oder Gramm Wasser,
– es ist lauwarm –
450 Gramm Mehl,
einen Teelöffel Salz
und 45 Gramm Olivenöl.
Das ist mein Zauberstab.
Mit diesem werde ich jetzt die Hefe
mit dem Wasser und dem Zucker verrühren.
Und wenn ein Löffelchen voll Zucker
bitt're Medizin versüßt,
Medizin versüßt, Medizin versüßt!
Und wenn mein Löffelchen voll Zucker
bitt're Medizin versüßt,
dann schmeckt sie gleich
genauso gut!
Nein, irgendwie war der Text anders.
Egal.
[Musik]
Und jetzt wird dieses Hefegemisch
wie durch Zauberei aufgehen.
Das heißt, ihr lasst das jetzt, wenn ihr möchtet,
einfach 15 Minuten bei Raumtemperatur stehen,
bis es blubbert.
Dann seht ihr auch, ob die Hefe wirklich schön funktioniert.
Ihr könnt sie aber auch direkt weiter verarbeiten.
Aber das Voraufgehen bewirkt,
dass der Hefeteig auch gleich schneller aufgeht.
Und ich mache das jetzt so:
Ich gehe jetzt zum Backofen
und
eins, zwei, drei,
wie durch Zauberei
habe ich hier mein Hefewasser
mit Blubberbläschen.
Ja.
Das kommt jetzt hier direkt alles in meine Rührschüssel
mit dem kompletten Mehl.
Dann das Hefewasser.
Dann wird das jetzt hier verrührt.
Und ganz zum Schluss gebt ihr das Salz
und das Öl hinzu.
Denn so kann die Hefe wunderbar aufgehen.
Ich bin gespannt,
wie lange ich meine Mary-Poppins-Stimme
in diesem Video beibehalten werde.
Aber ich bin gerade in Mary-Poppins-Stimmung.
Und jetzt knetet ihr den Teig
für etwa zehn Minuten,
bis er schön geschmeidig ist.
Das geht bei mir natürlich viel schneller.
Denn ich kann zaubern.
Chim-Chimeney!
Fertig!
Jetzt ist ein supergeschmeidiger Pizzateig entstanden.
Und ich fette die Schüssel einfach mit dem
Rest Öl hier
und lasse dann den Teig aufgehen,
entweder eine Stunde abgedeckt bei Raumtemperatur
oder eine halbe Stunde bei Gärstufe im Dampfbackofen.
Und dann kann ich eigentlich schon mal
die Füllung vorbereiten
beziehungsweise den Belag.
Für den Belag brauche ich
Tomatenmark,
– das sind 150 Gramm –
50 Gramm Wasser,
etwas Knoblauch.
Ich verwende noch Sucuk.
Hier habe ich noch etwas Kaşar-Käse,
Oregano,
Salz und Pfeffer.
Also mehr braucht man hier wirklich nicht.
Und es geht supersupereinfach.
Ich nehme jetzt das Tomatenmark
und, weil es einfach sehr stark konzentriert ist,
gebe ich das Wasser dazu.
Eine Knoblauchknolle.
Nein, eine Knoblauchzehe.
Und ihr könnt die Pizza-Donuts
jetzt wirklich auch belegen, wie ihr möchtet.
Ich habe da so was im Kopf.
Deswegen probiere ich es mal aus.
Guckt mal. Wenn ihr eine Knoblauchpresse benutzt,
müsst ihr den Knoblauch nicht schälen.
Denn er wird durchgedrückt
und es bleibt einfach die Haut zurück
– die Schale.
Haut klingt so ein bisschen eklig.
Die Schale bleibt zurück.
Dann mit Salz und Pfeffer würzen.
Es sieht immer nur so nach viel aus, aber
es ist gar nicht so viel.
Oregano mit rein.
Huch!
Hoppala!
Ernsthaft?
[Musik]
Kurz zur Seite.
Und beim Käse nehmt ihr jetzt einen,
der einfach wunderbar schmilzt,
entweder Kaşar-Käse
– der schmilzt echt extrem gut und schmeckt gut –
oder einen Gouda zum Beispiel.
Da muss ich aber...
Und jetzt einfach grob reiben.
[Musik]
Da, muss ich echt sagen, bin ich
der totale Verfechter von geriebenem Käse in Tüten.
Josh, hast du geriebenen Käse in Tüten zu Hause?
>> JOSH: Ja.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
>> SALLY: Nein.
Denn,
ganz ehrlich, so Käse am Stück ist zum einen günstiger,
zum anderen hält er länger
und man spart sich einfach die Trennmittel in der Tüte.
Und deswegen gibt es bei uns keinen geriebenen Käse,
sondern wir reiben ihn einfach.
Und ihr könnt ja auch einfach so Käse am Stück
auch in größeren Mengen kaufen,
könnt ihn reiben und auch einfrieren
und habt dann immer was auf Vorrat.
Aber ich finde, so ein Käse ist wirklich schnell gerieben.
Und da sparen wir uns
zum einen die Mehrverpackung, die dadurch entsteht,
und die Trennmittel im Käse.
Ja.
Also eigentlich habe ich jetzt alles vorbereitet.
Guckt einmal.
Soße, Käse, Belag.
Was halt echt megaperfekt wäre,
da es ja Pizza-Donuts werden,
wenn ihr kleine Salamis habt,
die so ganz klein sind, so dünne.
Ich glaube, ich steche so ein paar aus
einfach so der Optik halber.
Oder ihr könnt sie auch schneiden.
Dann sind es kleine Dreiecke.
Sieht auch nicht schlecht aus, gell?
>> JOSH: Hm, so Minipizzastückchen.
>> SALLY: So Minipizzastückchen.
Ich glaube, das machen wir.
Denn der Schwabe sagt sich:
"Wenn sie das jetzt aussticht,
was macht sie dann mit dem Rest?"
[Musik]
Ta-daa!
Ja, so Minidreiecke, das sieht doch süß aus.
Minipizzastückchen auf Donut-Pizza
– Pizza-Donuts.
[Musik]
>> ELA: Was machst du da?
>> SALLY: Ich mache Pizza-Donuts!
>> ELA: Oh, lecker!
Wo sind Pizza-Donuts?
>> SALLY: Hast du Lust auf Pizza-Donuts?
Äh, Entschuldigung? Ist hier ein Sucuk-Dieb unterwegs?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich habe hier noch mehr Sucuk!
Möchtest du?
>> ELA: Ja.
Schmeckt gar nicht mehr so scharf.
>> SALLY: Mein Papa würde jetzt sagen:
"Kimin kızı? Kimin kızı?",
also: "Wessen Tochter ist das?"
Murat.
>> ELA: Ein Stück Käse!
>> SALLY: Sieht aus wie Käse, gell?
Schatz, aber jetzt geh zu deiner Freundin wieder rüber!
>> ELA: Eine noch für meine Freundin?
>> SALLY: Eine Scheibe, ja.
Da. Dann nimm noch eine Scheibe für deine Freundin mit.
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Los, kleiner Schmetterling oder Fee oder Elfe...
>> ELA: Ich bin eine Fee.
>> SALLY: Ach, du bist eine Fee. Entschuldigung.
>> ELA: Weil ich habe doch keine Fühler!
>> SALLY: Ah, stimmt.
Schließt du die Tür bitte?
Jetzt geht es direkt ans Ausrollen.
Und zwar nehmt ihr ein wenig Mehl,
dann euren Teig,
der jetzt auch so wunderbar aufgegangen sein sollte,
und jetzt auf 1 cm Stärke ausrollen.
Ich mache das jetzt hier mit diesen Abstandsringen.
Ich habe die hier einfach draufgeklemmt
und reingeschraubt.
Oder ihr versucht, das eben einfach so
gleichmäßig auszurollen.
Mh.
Ich glaube, ich nehme doch 8 mm.
Denn die lasse ich jetzt noch gut luftig aufgehen.
Okay. Kommando zurück.
Oder doch 5 mm?
Nee, die sollen nicht zu dünn werden.
8 mm.
[Musik]
So.
Und jetzt werden die Donuts ausgestochen.
Ich nehme jetzt hier zwei Ausstecher.
Einer hat 9 cm, der andere 4,5 cm im Durchmesser.
Und jetzt kann ich hier schön alles ausstechen.
[Musik]
Dann das Loch in der Mitte ausstechen.
Und das sieht jetzt so ziemlich dünn aus,
aber der geht ja gleich noch auf.
Das heißt, ich setze das hier direkt
auf ein Blech mit viel Abstand.
Und den restlichen Teig knete ich noch mal zusammen,
lasse ihn kurz ruhen,
bis ich die dann hier bestrichen habe,
und dann kann ich den auch noch mal ausrollen
und eben auch noch mal so verarbeiten.
[Musik]
So. Dass er nicht austrocknet.
Jetzt streiche ich hier das Tomatenmark drauf,
also die Pizzasoße.
Ganz vorsichtig.
Und die Sucuk-Stücke und auch den Käse
streue ich aber dann erst später drauf.
Denn ich lasse sie jetzt erst mal
ordentlich noch mal aufgehen.
Dann habe ich ja auch mehr Fläche, die ich belegen kann.
Und dann fällt jetzt auch erst mal nichts runter.
[Musik]
Zwei Bleche gehen jetzt gerade schon auf.
Hier habe ich noch die restlichen vier.
Den Teig habe ich jetzt noch übrig.
Und jetzt guckt mal.
Da mache ich es jetzt einfach so,
damit wirklich der komplette Teig aufgebraucht wird.
Ich forme ihn zu einem Strang,
lege den so rum
und verbinde das so.
Hm?
>> JOSH: Krass!
>> SALLY: Das war wie in der Bagel-Produktion.
Warte. Ich mache es noch mal
zum Mitverfolgen.
Also einmal so.
So machen die auch die Bagels.
Das habe ich mal gesehen.
Dann rumlegen und dann einfach so.
Zack!
Und dann haben wir bis zum Schluss
den kompletten Teig fertig.
Ich bestreiche die jetzt noch ganz kurz.
Die anderen sind echt schon gut aufgegangen.
Und damit geht es dann gleich weiter
mit dem Belegen.
[Musik]
Na, ich glaube, so ein bisschen
Tomatensoße verteile ich noch drüber.
Ja, also, wenn ihr seht, es wurde ein bisschen
zu wenig,
gebt noch was drauf.
Ich muss sagen, ich mag auch diese Schildkrötenoptik,
dass es oben wie so ein Schildkrötenpanzer aussieht
durch die Risse.
Das ist gerade eigentlich
– dieses Zubereiten ist gerade so eine Folter,
weil es hier drin so lecker riecht.
Eben waren schon Vivi und Marcel da
und haben auch schon so:
"Mmh! Was gibt es denn hier?"
[Musik]
Hier belege ich jetzt gerade die Pizza-Donuts
mit Sucuk und Käse.
Und dann kommen sie direkt in den vorgeheizten Backofen.
Ich backe sie jetzt bei Ober-/Unterhitze,
bis sie halt gar sind.
Da ich sie noch nie gemacht habe,
weiß ich nicht, wann sie gar sind.
Aber ich schreibe es euch dann rein,
sobald ich einen Erfahrungswert habe.
O Mann!
Ich will endlich, dass die backen, und dann
will ich sie essen können.
[Musik]
So sehen die Pizza-Donuts jetzt aus.
Ich muss sagen, ich glaube, ich probiere es
beim nächsten Mal mit der Pizzastufe dann doch.
Denn sie sind mir teilweise doch ein bisschen zu hell.
Also sie sind super durchgebacken
und auch unten schön hellbraun.
Aber ich glaube, Pizzastufe wäre vielleicht sogar besser.
Ich probiere es nächstes Mal aus.
Ich glaube, das war jetzt nicht das letzte Mal,
dass ich sie zubereitet habe.
Und jetzt darf Josh probieren.
Josh steht normalerweise hinter der Kamera, aber komm.
>> JOSH: Pizza!
Da muss ich mal probieren.
>> SALLY: Und ich muss sagen,
dieses Endstück, das ist schon fast das schönste.
>> JOSH: Das wurde richtig cool.
>> SALLY: Das wurde richtig schön!
>> JOSH: Ich bin voll überrascht, wie gut das wird.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, ich finde von dem,
also bei dem die Form sogar am schönsten.
>> JOSH: Ja, das hat
– also fairerweise muss man sagen,
das hat die richtige Donut-Form erreicht.
>> SALLY: Ja. Ja.
>> JOSH: Und die sind Pizzakringel.
>> SALLY: Auch schön.
Pizzakringel.
Ja. Komm, wir probieren.
>> JOSH: Ich bin gespannt.
Sollen wir den kleinen uns teilen?
>> SALLY: Ach ja, komm.
>> JOSH: Oder magst du nicht vor der Kamera probieren?
>> SALLY: Doch, ich probiere.
Aber ich glaube, dass die anderen lockerer sind als der,
weil der war ja so das Endstück.
>> JOSH: Ah, stimmt.
Aber ich muss sagen, ich mag Pizza lieber,
wenn sie ein bisschen krosser ist, normalerweise.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> JOSH: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Geschmacklich echt cool.
>> JOSH: Hammer!
>> SALLY: Mh.
Ich meine, so eine normale Pizza
kann man auch aus der Hand essen,
aber man braucht halt immer so die zweite Hand für innen
>> JOSH: Hm. Oh, stimmt!
>> SALLY: Und dann fällt dir alles so runter.
>> JOSH: Es kippt immer die Spitze runter.
>> SALLY: Man verbrennt sich da das Zahnfleisch hinten,
hinter den Schneidezähnen.
Ich habe voll
Tomatenmark da.
Du auch.
>> JOSH: Oh!
Okay.
>> SALLY: Also ich finde sie echt cool.
>> JOSH: Mega!
Das ist ja auch so ein Crowdfeeder, oder?
So für so eine Party.
>> SALLY: Definitiv ein Crowdfeeder.
>> JOSH: So zum Zugreifen.
Einfach hinstellen, jeder kann zugreifen.
>> SALLY: Ja. Also ich glaube, man könnte sie
tatsächlich noch einen Ticken doch kleiner machen.
Ich hatte Angst.
Ich wusste nicht so genau, wie weit geht der Teig auf.
Aber man kann sich da eigentlich
an meinem normalen Donut-Video ein bisschen orientieren.
Ich wusste nur nicht so...
Eigentlich hätte ich es ja genauso groß machen können.
Egal.
Das war jetzt ein Test.
Und ihr könnt sie ja einfach anders machen.
Ich finde es jedenfalls ziemlich cool.
Probiert sie gern aus.
Und ich finde,
>> JOSH: Richtig lecker!
>> SALLY: schon ein gutes Rezept.
Also
>> JOSH: Definitiv!
>> SALLY: bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschau!
>> JOSH: Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Ich bin übrigens auch auf TikTok jetzt.
Ja.
Ich habe es ausprobiert.
Ich habe jetzt schon die ersten paar Videos gemacht.
Zuerst habe ich nicht ganz verstanden, was TikTok ist,
aber ich glaube, so langsam,
so langsam wird es.
Meine Kleine, die Samira,
– die Große –
die ist meine Lehrerin.
Sie zeigt mir, wie TikTok geht.
Tschüss!
[Musik]